a constant through line throughout
Barbie is that Ken is hopelessly in love
with Barbie who just doesn't fully
reciprocate his feelings sure there as
Ken puts it boyfriend girlfriend but
Barbie never wants Ken to be at her
house because it's always girls night
beyond that they don't even kiss Ken
leans in and kisses the air near
Barbie's face and then tells her how
wonderful the non-kiss was before asking
if he can spend the night
I might still
why because we're just working boyfriend
easy way
actually not sure during an interview
alongside Robbie with people Gosling
said that the actors and creatives
working on Barbie tried to figure out
how Ken and Barbie would even
successfully kiss but it was just way
too weird Gosling said it was so funny
trying to figure out what their idea of
kissing might be I'm so glad all of that
got cut out